[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue dansions sortait la
nouvelle émission de télé 78 aujourd'hui
on reçoit christian guémy alias c215
bonjour bonjour alors on est ce soir au
château de maisons laffitte
à partir de demain on pourra voir votre
exposition on pourra y trouver des
personnes qui ont vécu ici qui ont vécu
à maisons laffitte qui sont ces
personnes en fait il s'agit d'un d'une
exposition qui présente des portraits
peints au pochoir sur différents objets
et ces objets sont présentés dans
presque chacune des salles du château
on trouve aussi des portraits autour du
château peint sur le mobilier urbain de
maisons laffitte il ya 22 portraits qui
ont été sélectionnés par la
conservatrice du château moi même et le
service culture de la ville et il s'agit
aussi bien bien sûr deux des rois qui
ont vécu ici ou qui sont passées des
grands propriétaires du château et des
mécènes de la ville mais pas seulement
puisqu'on y trouve des gens qui ont vécu
à maison qu'ils sont cons rayonnait eux
aussi des sportifs des romanciers comme
martin du gard jules vallès ou
cocteau mais voilà des gens tous les
gens qui finalement ont pu par leur
rayonnement distinguer maisons laffitte
et donc ses portraits ils sont pas faits
au pinceau vous utilisez quoi comme
technique
moi je travaille au pochoir c'est ce qui
me permet de prendre assez vite dans la
rue sur du mobilier urbain des portraits
de diverses tailles ce sont pour la
plupart sont des portraits qui sont pas
très très grand parce qu'il s'agissait
pas de s'imposer à la vue des gens même
dans le château j'essaie d'avoir un
travail dit contextuel où je m'inspire
de l'environnement pourquoi mais pour ce
serait se fondent et qu'on puisse les
remarques et si on le souhaite vous ne
pas les remarquer si on est inattentif
et donc c'est vraiment une technique qui
m'a permis de travailler très vite dans
la rue puisque j'ai peint les 22
portraits en une journée
une sale journée les tous oui mais la
préparation a duré un nom c'est à dire
qu'il ya deux ans quand j'ai exposé au
panthéon dans la crypte du panthéon avec
un parcours dans et autour du panthéon
avec des personnalités des portraits de
personnalités qui repose au panthéon
j'ai pu rencontrer la conservatrice du
château de maisons laffitte qui m'a
proposé ce projet qui s'appelle épopée
mansonnienne et qui en fait permet aux
grands aux petits de découvrir le
château et son histoire mais aussi les
rues l'environnement l'histoire de la
ville de maisons-laffitte
et justement à qui elle s'adresse cette
exposition au plus grand nombre et on
espère que bien sûr tous les amateurs de
street art ou les gens qui suivent mon
travail depuis maintenant 15 ans en tout
cas elles vont avoir plaisir à retrouver
des nouvelles oeuvres mais également
peut-être aussi aux gens de maison
laffitte qui vont pouvoir redécouvrir
leur ville sous un nouvel angle
parce qu'en général les
des emplacements sur lesquels
j'interviens sont pas nécessairement des
emplacements de grandes expositions il
s'agit de boîtes à feu deux boîtes aux
lettres des éléments en fait de mobilier
urbain qu'on remarque que jamais et
j'espère d avoir valorisé
j'espère aussi que tout le personnel
pédagogique en tout cas de la ville pour
y emmener les enfants parce que c'est
une manière de présenter l'histoire ou
deux en tout cas de stimuler les enfants
à découvrir l'histoire ou un bâtiment en
tout cas de cette qualité mais avec avec
peut-être un accès un peu plus facile et
donc est ce que vous vous avez un coup
de coeur un portrait coups de coeur
parmi ceux là alors moi j'ai bien sûr le
portrait de jean gabin qui a été un
vraiment un mansonnien célèbre notamment
parce que j'ai un petit garçon qui a un
17 mois maintenant et qui s'appelle
lui-même gabin ce qui fait que les
portraits de gabin occupe une place
importante notamment dans la vitrine
consacrée au 20e siècle qui se trouve
dans le château du street art dans un
château comme celui là il y avait une
volonté un peu de mélange des styles
en fait on a l'habitude lorsqu'on est un
artiste de street art à s'adresser
directement au public son médiation et à
faire sortir l'art dans la rue ou de le
faire apparaître là on l'attend pas mais
je pense que c'est aussi un endroit là
où on n'attend pas cette forme
d'expression et ce style que de se
retrouver dans une ville comme maisons
laffitte qui est pas nécessairement une
ville très axé sur le hip hop vous ne me
tenez encore moins dans ce château mais
j'essaie toujours de faire les choses
pour que chacun puisse rencontrer
l'autre c'est à dire que les amateurs du
street art puisse rencontrer cet univers
où que les amateurs de cet univers
puisse rencontrer le street art
parce que jusque important je pense
c'est de rassembler les gens et on
pourra la retrouver quand cette
expression les dates
l'exposition dure jusqu'au 30 novembre
peut-être qu'elle sera prolongée parce
que les conditions actuelles en tout cas
de visitorat sont assez éprouvante mais
ce qui compte c'est que le parcours dans
la ville dont on peut trouver en tout
cas le plan à l'office du tourisme
juste à côté du rer quand on arrive à
maisons-laffitte ou qu'on peut trouver
également au château
cette exposition là une exposition hors
les murs si on sortait celle-là elle
restera indéfiniment
très bien merci d'avoir suivi cette
émission et on se retrouve bientôt pour
un nouveau magazine
[Musique]